The first time
as President Joe
Biden gave the graduation speech
to the US Air Force Academy's
class of 2023
and just after all,
the graduates had received
their diplomas.
President Biden
appeared to trip and fall
as his heading back to his seat on stage.
He appeared to land,
as you can see that video there
on his right hip.
CNN's Priscilla Alvarez
joins me now live Priscilla.
Following that fall
he seems to have gotten up,
went back to his seat,
seems to be doing okay.
Do we know what happened? And we didn't.
Do we know his date now? Right.
I mean, he seemed to be in fine spirits
after returning to his seat.
He was helped out by a group of men,
including an Air Force official
and two Secret Service agents.
But all of that after
what was a long five hour
ceremony where he had he had shaken hands
with the cadets
as they were graduating over 900 of them.
So that came towards
the end of the ceremony.
But really, the focus of the ceremony
and his commencement address
was focused on the world and the globe
and how it's changing.
Abby, there are a lot of concerns
among voters, Democrats included,
about President Biden's age
and about his ability
to serve for six more years,
five more years.
And then there was an incident today.
We shouldn't
make too big a deal out of it.
We're told that he's not hurt
but it certainly doesn't help.
He fell.
He tripped
while walking during the Air Force
Academy commencement ceremony today.
He tripped on something either
a sandbag or some sort of cable
or something.
This this does come as he's facing
growing scrutiny
about his age and and wherewithal.
Yeah.
I mean, look, this is not good.
It's not anything that the White House
or his campaign wants for two reasons.
One, the optics of it are absolutely bad.
But secondly, I mean, in general,
it is not good for
the president, especially one of
President Biden's age to take a fall.
Falls are dangerous, actually,
from a factual perspective.
And so, look,
this is not good news
for the White House.
They don't want to be dealing
with this narrative.
I've also been hearing
from a lot of Republicans
who are very eagerly,
eagerly sending around old clips of,
you know, articles
talking about when
Trump kind of tiptoed down a slope
and seemed to be worried
about falling in a situation
and how that was interpreted
by the media.
I think the White House
is now going to be
dealing with something
they've been dealing with,
which is concerns
about the president's age,
but also Republicans in particular
trying to
make this a contrast
between Trump and Biden.
And that's not the conversation
they want to have at all.
So it hasn't happened.
They'll have to deal with it.
But but it's certainly not something
I think the White House
is particularly happy about, though.
They couldn't do anything about it.
It reminds me of a very different dynamic
when Bob Dole,
who was the presidential candidate
in for Republicans
in 1996, fell off a stage
and the media
made a big deal out of that obviously
very different age contrast
with incumbent President Bill Clinton.
Thanks to all of you.